so when you start a company with a name
like mother duck you have two options
one is you can run away from it and get
offended when people call you a mother
Ducker or pretend you have no idea what
they're talking about or you can embrace
it you know embrace the duck puns and
sometimes even wear the wear the duck
suit
um you know so when Pete you know asked
you know hey I'll give you a uh a
keynote at data Council this amazing
conference with all these amazing people
uh in exchange for a little light
humiliation
it was pretty clear which one which one
of those things I was going to uh was
going to do but he didn't say I had to
wear it the whole time so if you don't
mind I'm going to take this off it might
be a little distracting
[Applause]
I do have duck socks
I won't I'm not gonna strip anymore
during this during this presentation I
promise
okay so who who am I Pete gave me a
great uh great lead-in but just what you
know why am I talking about this wearing
a duck suit Etc I was the guy that used
to go around the world talking about how
big data was going to change everything
uh I was you know an engineer on
bigquery was the kind of the guy that
liked to like to give give talks and so
they would put me in front of crowds and
I would
run a query over a petabyte of data uh
and uh you know impress people that hey
you could query a petabyte of data uh I
didn't tell people how much it cost it
was like a five thousand dollar query
it's like that was kind of beside the
scenes but the thing that I kind of
rapidly realized is that you know none
of our customers are actually running
queries that look anything anything like
this and started to kind of an idea kind
of percolate that you know hey some of
our you know a lot of our big query
customers don't actually use Big Data
um so I'm gonna you know give a talk uh
it's you know if you've read the big
data is dead uh post I'm going to
elaborate on on some of the things go a
little bit deeper on on some things also
talk about what
changes if uh if you believe that big
data is in fact is in fact dead
um you're gonna tell a story with graphs
the the graphs are designed to be
directionally correct not not actually
correct they're sort of hand-drawn I
don't have access to that data anymore
and if I did I wouldn't be able to share
it with you so it's actually sort of the
best of Best of Both Worlds um but it is
based on stuff that I kind of have seen
in in the real world
um so how many people have seen a graph
like this uh in somebody's slide deck
you know basically this is the scare
graph you know big data is coming
everything is changing and uh and of
course you better buy what I'm what I'm
selling
um you know this graph has been used
this you know they changed the date
every you know every year kind of the
date gets a little bit further out and
the graph goes a little bit a little bit
higher up but
um you know it's it's uh
uh you'd think that after 15 years like
kind of the the you know everything
would have everything would have changed
and um you know the last few years or so
I've you know been looking at at
customers and how people were using data
and you know what people were saying
about data a single store like for
example our most popular size of of
instance was the smallest one and that
was a quarter of the size of the
smallest snowflake instance and people
kept asking for smaller and it's like
well I just don't have that much data
and at bigquery there were just tons and
tons of customers who you know were
using it uh with uh with with really
pretty pretty modest amounts of amounts
of data
uh so if you've seen DB engines it's
this like database people live by it uh
you know they they check it every every
month to see how their favorite
databases are doing but it basically
tracks the popularity of databases over
time uh so mongodb is the most popular
nosql database most popular sort of
scale out database MySQL is as a scale
up database
um and you kind of you think that these
lines would be would be converging if
Big Data had been changing had been
changing everything if you look at the
new SQL databases they're not even close
to
um the the uh this is the oltp side the
olap side looks a little bit different
just because I think the cloud
transition has really dominated a lot of
these a lot of these effects but clearly
like
old school single single node systems or
have not become irrelevant
and you know one of the reasons is
people don't have that much data so like
if you look at like the like the
bigquery customers that we had you know
we had a couple customers that had
hundreds of petabytes of data the next
largest customer was sort of like the
tens of petabytes of data and then
because it's really this sort of like
really fast fast drop off and there's a
really long long tail of you know people
who need to do analytics
um with modest amounts of data if you
just think about being like uh so you're
a B2B SAS company I was you know single
store is a B2B stock company so you've
got a thousand a thousand customers like
that's not an unreasonable or a small
number of number of customers if you
have to make Enterprise deals every time
if you have a thousand data points over
all those customers for three years like
that's a billion data points uh maybe
100 gigabytes worth of worth of data uh
so it's sort of pretty easy to see that
like you can run a really successful
business without having without having a
huge amount of data
uh this is somewhat of a a technical
point when uh you know nowadays uh
separation of storage and compute has
been has been uh really you know
commoditized or is is table Stakes so
you know bigquery snowflake uh have a
separation of storage compute redshift
uh neon has added that on the on the
oltp side
uh and people kind of talk about
separation of storage and compute as if
they're kind of equal like okay well
sometimes I need a ton of storage
sometimes you need a ton of data
um but what happens kind of at the
larger data sizes is that um you end up
not needing much more compute so like
this is this this graph here is a log
linear chart so like if you increase
your data size by 10x you might only
need one more one more compute node
um and it's just you know there's a
couple reasons for that and and I'll get
into it in these these next couple
slides but I think this is something
that's that's kind of under under
appreciated so one of the reasons for it
is people end up using less data than
you'd think so the the 90th percentile
query in bigquery was 100 megabytes of
data and this is of customers these are
like tiny customers these are customers
spending over a thousand dollars a month
uh these are people that are doing kind
of real world you know real world
production analytics uh they just do a
ton of ton of small small queries
um you know the uh you know you don't
have to get up very high and you know
very very far along the along the size
to uh to get to kind of the 99th 99.9
percentile yes there are some queries
that are that are larger than that but
in general those are uh those are really
ones where a human isn't present so if
you think about kind of human in the
loop like I'm running a dashboard you
really don't want to be to be crunching
you know massive amounts of data because
like it's going to be it's going to be
slow uh and it's going to be expensive
like so like you know people have
figured out a way to make uh you know
large scale queries fast by paralyzing
but they haven't really figured out a
way to make them inexpensive
yeah it's my you know five thousand
dollar petabyte query
the other thing is you know just there's
a real recency bias to how people access
their data you know most of the data
that's on disk just ends up sitting
there because you know the vast majority
of the queries that people do it's like
what happened in the last what happened
yesterday
uh what happened in the last week what
happened the last two weeks whatever the
last month when you get past a month uh
it you know data gets pretty quiet so
one of the things that you know we did
in big you know this you know
understanding this data comes from I was
trying to do some analysis on how do we
how do we keep how do we get people to
keep their data because if they're not
querying their old data then chances are
they're not gonna they're not gonna keep
it and for us it was actually you know
really we had really good margins on old
data that just sits there as you as you
may be able to to imagine
um
another kind of interesting thing that's
happened that's happened over time since
uh you know the last 15 years is scale
up has really become a lot more a lot
more viable you know in um you know
Google produced a series of a series of
papers uh in the you know the early
2000s they really changed how people
built uh build Data Systems first there
was mapreduce then GFS and bigtable then
Dremel and um you know after that
everybody's you know starts thinking
about how do we how do we scale out on
commodity Hardware instead of instead of
scaling instead of scaling up uh CTO of
a database company said to me you know a
year ago
um you know hey if you uh if you're not
a scale out uh database people are going
to laugh at you
as you may notice I'm not so worried
about people laughing at me but I think
there's also
um there's also something to be said for
for for scaling scaling up so in you
know 2006 when AWS came out the largest
AWS instance you could get was you know
one core and uh and two gigs of RAM
there's a lot of workloads that don't
necessarily fit in that
um now now the reason that scale up used
to be more expensive is because a larger
machine would cost you more than like a
2X machine size would cost you 4X or 10x
in um uh in actually by buying that
hardware and but if you look at the
actual like physical server sizes that
AWS is using they're pretty monstrous
like so they you know and they don't
charge you if you get half that machine
if you get two halves of that machine
versus one hole of that machine it costs
the same
um you know so the the standard
instances are 64 uh 64 cores 250 256
gigs of RAM uh the standard memory
optimized instances there's a bunch of
different different ones you know
terabyte and a half of ram 192 cores
then they even go up to 445 cores uh and
24 terabytes of ram there's not a whole
lot of workloads that don't fit in in
that that amount of that amount of
Hardware uh the other reason that you
know people used to to not trust scale
up is so if you have an on-prem data
center you buy this really expensive
piece of piece of Hardware to run your
to run your database server
um you need to have another one in case
that one breaks and uh the cloud has
really changed that because like
Amazon's got plenty so like your you
know your database breaks or you have a
crash or something happens chances are
you won't even know it Amazon will just
kind of replace it from underneath you
um so the Dremel paper came out in 2008
I believe and it kind of blew people's
mind with how fast you could you could
query really large amounts of data
um so I kind of wanted to look at the
Benchmark that they ran and see if you
can replicate that on a single on a
single machine so this is just sort of
like kind of theoretical numbers I
didn't you know this isn't saying like
you know duct TB is is uh can can do
this but
um
you know the um
the the math works so uh you know
basically there's there's enough CPU
so so what they did is they ran the you
know query one which is the one they
have the uh the graphs on they ran
um uh over 87 billion rows like the
overall data set was I think something
like 70 billion or 70 terabytes
um but they only it's a column uh column
store so they only had to read half a
terabyte and they did that across 3 000
nodes in about 20 seconds
and uh kind of on Modern on a modern
scale up system so this is AWS i4i you
know you can get those in a whole bunch
of different uh different regions
there's enough CPU
um to to be able to that based on some
like published benchmarks that single
store has come out about how many rows
they can process uh they have you know
plenty of uh you know plenty of ability
to process that many rows
um there's enough RAM to sort of to to
be able to to have all that in in Ram
um the uh if if it's cached in SSD
there's plenty of SSD so basically
um the only thing that doesn't work is
if you have to read it cold so the
things that a single single node
instance still doesn't doesn't do
ideally is is have massive amounts of i
o
um but there are kind of newer instances
coming that that have uh have more more
I O for example there's a there's a trn1
instance that has 800 gigabits uh of of
uh of networking and that actually is
enough to to uh to do this so you know
kind of what seemed like like uh like
science fiction because you could do
just massive amounts of of work all at
the same time now you know you can uh
you know just spin spin it up on on AWS
so the kind of where the uh the front
here for Big Data is has been has been
receding so it used to be the kind of
like okay big data I've got gigabytes
that's big data
um you know the the frontier for which
you really have to use Big Data
techniques has been has been increasing
over time and likely that will is going
to continue uh uh to uh to increase
so you know let's say you have big you
have you have lots of data and your data
workloads are actually pretty large
um
uh you know why else might Big Data not
be not be something that um uh that you
should be dealing with and so this is
the same graph as the first graph so the
first graph just said bytes and time but
bytes and costs are really the same and
so uh over time
your if your data is increasing
exponentially your costs are also
increasing exponentially and any
exponential cost progression eventually
is going to kill you and so you're going
to have to figure out some way around
this now there's a couple different ways
of doing it one you can sort of do
filtering at the source two you could
you know go back and look at your old
data uh to see what it is that you could
you could throw out
um the highest powered room that I've
ever been in was like Google had this
technical Advisory board with a bunch of
Fortune 50 ctOS and uh you know we asked
them what do you think about data lakes
and um you know these people didn't
agree on anything like one of them was
like talking about hey what are you guys
doing on Quantum uh and uh but the one
thing that they did agree in is like
they hated their data lakes and they're
like they're just data data swamps and
they're really expensive I have no idea
what's there the problem is with like
gdpr and all these privacy regulations
if you don't know what data you have
then uh you know chances are you're not
actually complying with these with these
things
um you know from a legal perspective you
know data can can be data can be a legal
liability we've gotten used to having
um
retention periods for for email so that
you know that email you wrote about you
know scamming your customers uh you know
can't be found in in Discovery Well if
it's in the logs then it can be found in
Discovery and not saying you should be
scamming your customers but sometimes
you know there's things that you things
things that are broken uh there's other
bugs maybe you overcharged or something
again not saying you should do any of
these things but
um but having that data forever is is
basically you're having a legal
liability forever
um so you know being able to summarize
the data it can be can be super helpful
especially if you consider like
most of the time you actually look at
the old data you rerun the same query
that you already ran you just add a new
day and the new day is like is a new day
it's not an old day so
um you know you can generally summarize
that data data you know the the
interpretation of data changes over time
so your ability to actually extract good
insights from older data is uh is
decreasing and I probably don't even
have to I could have skipped this slide
for you folks because you probably know
all this stuff and intrinsically like
deal with this deal with this every day
but um
you know I think as as uh you know
because the data generation
is increasing over time you know we are
going to have to increasingly
increasingly handle this increasingly be
able to sort of cut it down cut it down
to size
so just to sort of summarize so far is
like you know
yes there are you know some people that
are that do still for whom big data is
still is still important but I would say
that that's not the vast majority of
people
um you know that would have to be if you
really have a truly large amount of data
uh you need to query it all at once
um it doesn't fit on one machine we've
seen that that actually is you know one
machine can can fit a ton of work
um and you shouldn't be summarizing or
or deleting some of that data
um so let's say you agree that
um the data size is not
everything and maybe it shouldn't be
driving how you're designing and
building your your data system so what
you know what changes sometimes it's
nice to think about just in it in
general like okay if you remove this
constraint that was driving how I was
doing things like what what would change
about the world
um well first one you know is don't
don't be afraid to uh don't be afraid to
scale up uh you know everybody you know
scale up is is
um is entirely is entirely reasonable
um scale up architectures scale up
systems
um you know I think are are now going to
be going to be more viable especially
especially in the cloud
you know clean up your data uh you know
again likely I don't need to tell
anybody to to do this but you know
organizing governance all the like all
the good stuff you can do to make sure
you don't have like you know uh nasty
nasty ugly data sitting around
um so this is an interesting one you
know when we started bigquery one of the
mantras what we had was it's from Jim
Gray the uh the touring Award winner uh
database uh um Guru uh for Microsoft
researcher Microsoft research and he
used to say you know when you have big
data you want to move the compute to the
data rather than the data to the compute
because actually the actual cost of
moving data is so is so expensive
let's say you you agree that you know
their data size might not be that large
uh you know that doesn't necessarily
hold anymore so can you actually take
your
uh your data and push it out to where
the user is
so like laptops these days like you know
I've got an M2 laptop uh you know on my
on my desk you know those are incredibly
powerful computers actually
um
uh George Fraser the the the CEO of
5tran just published a blog post the
other day where he compared uh and uh
you know duck DB running on his laptop
against a uh 16 core
cloud-based Data Warehouse on a uh you
know tpcds you know typical uh you know
database database Benchmark and his
laptop was faster
so that's just one that's just one
Benchmark but like people have a huge
amount of power on their on their on
their on their home computers and so if
you run a query
and you wait for you know three seconds
while this expensive Cloud resource is
uh is Computing Computing that result
you know meanwhile that cloud resource
is contested by you know 60 other people
in the organization that are trying to
trying to use that same Hardware
um and meanwhile this like incredibly
powerful machine on your on your that
you have on your desk is sitting idle
like that doesn't seem an ideal use of
of resources so kind of I think there's
a new a new frontier where we can
actually start pushing work out to the
to the end user and not having to rely
on on expensive cloud cloud Hardware
this also comes into a play when you
know when data is generated let's say
um you know you have an iot scenario or
your something is on on mobile or you
have
um data is being generated in a
distributed fashion in general the way
we we handle this is we kind of move all
the data to the centralized location and
um and then we do the the computation on
it but you know actually we can actually
do the compute out where the uh the data
is actually produced
uh and the other thing is one size might
not fit all because I was mentioned
before the difference between
doing uh you know user in the loop
versus user not in the loop you know if
there is a lot of data being generated
you might have to do some expensive
transformations of that data uh that
might need more scale out techniques but
in general when you're you know the
things where you have human in the loop
you're running your dashboards you're
running your you're running your
analytics
um you know that can be that can be done
on a on a different system
and
um you know of course life is better
with a doc has anybody heard of a
database called duct TB
all right everybody is everybody's heard
about it has anybody heard how it could
change your life
I I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go I'm not
gonna go into into uh into too much uh
duck posting but I will kind of go into
a perhaps an extended analogy and this
is uh something we used to we used to
talk about at Google we used to talk
about kind of the overall analytics
systems as a as a Happy Meal so you had
your transformation ingestion
orchestration as the french fries you
know French fries are
um you know the kind of Mainstay of the
Happy Meal
um uh perhaps underrated uh but
um but incredibly important
uh then you had the you know the
visualization the bi the data science
the modeling
um and this is sort of the the suite and
the kind of the fun you know the the fun
part of it
um and then in the middle is kind of the
core is your your analytics uh and your
analytics engine uh and you'll have to
forgive me for kind of putting you know
the analytics engine at the middle
um you know that was my job
but as anybody who
um either remembers being you know
eating Happy Meals ordering Happy Meals
or has you know knows people who order
Happy Meals like what's the one thing
that this is missing
a toy exactly that's why I brought one
with me
so what happens when you add a duck to
this
um so you know visualization layer the
bi layer let's say let's say you're
adding a deck now there's a bunch of
people already you know startups uh that
are in this you know folks that are in
this room that are adding duct TV to
their visualization layer duckdb runs in
the browser so they're adding kind of
web-based uh web browser based based
duckdb
um hex real data Omni observable uh
there's a there's a ton of a ton of
folks that are that are putting duck DB
in the browser because because it brings
like the power and the and the Express
expressiveness and the reactiveness to
their uh to the you to their user
interfaces
um so but you can also add adductv to
your
I was going to say to your French fries
uh to your two-year ingestion uh and
orchestration process so there is a
drbdbt connector
um there's duct TV being added for a
bunch of you know sort of data data
ingestion transformation tools and
that's one of the things actually that
um you know honest uh from uh you know
the the CEO of Dr B Labs has has talked
about is that you know there's more and
more people that are building pipelines
using using duck TV so this is sort of a
really powerful way of just sort of
being able to you know do your analytics
kind of wherever it wherever it lives
and then the last part is well if you uh
you know being able to put duckdb in
your do in your analytics now I think
this is so far less common but there's
something really cool about about this
is so basically if you have you
ingestion you talk to you when you're
ingesting the data uh Dr B when you're
visualizing the data duct TB when you're
analyzing the data sort of duct to be
all the way through you have this not a
modern data stack it's a modern duck
stack
and um they can be they can be super uh
they can be super powerful and um and
one other kind of just nice things that
I will I will mention is you know uh
when you have this many this many ducks
uh you need somebody to keep those ducks
in the line who's good at keeping ducks
in a line a mother duck
sorry for the sorry for the pun
um it comes it comes with a job
um but the other thing that kind of all
this is is you know is enabled by the
you know the sort of the the facts that
data size isn't the most important thing
because if you're if you have to be
dealing with massive data and if you're
like this you know my data is is huge
then you know okay you're not going to
want to put duck DB in the ingest or the
or the visualization and you're not
going to want to use it as your uh as
your as your storage layer but kind of
once you once you recognize that we're
kind of perhaps in a new in a new world
then
um you know it allows you to do all
sorts of uh nice duckiness
um that's that's it uh thanks everybody
[Music]